we did here by the way at our voicemail
number two one nine to david p we heard
from the kansas troll who you might
remember about a year ago pat he called
in and totally face-planted during a
live call and since then he basically
goes on hiatus for like three to six
months at a time and then leaves a
completely outrageous voicemail he's
done exactly that
he claims here that women use their
vaginas against men
god bless Brett Kavanaugh and all sorts
of other crazy stuff take a listen to
this yeah uh I wanted to say your take
on the Cavanaugh situation by the way it
god bless Brett cabin on the Cavanaugh
family your take is complete crap we all
know women in professional worlds but it
basically anywhere else have no problems
floating around but they call it sexual
assault and rape when they don't get you
know whatever promotion or whatever guy
they want it and women use their vaginas
as cloyd's against men and the majority
of women actually do orgasm during great
so by virtue of women are liars and this
woman's testimony should never have been
admissible in the courts was it yeah
Dave you are a complete pathetic [ __ ]
you may see it anemic queer that's
always on the YouTube screen your total
men Johnny no you little prick Pakman
there you go
this is a deeply deeply angry person
this is somebody who is in need of very
very serious intervention but the the
the reason I bring it to you is because
he gets to vote just like everybody else
right and this is this is actually what
we're up against
this is what we're fighting against and
when people don't have a real argument
they do get upset in the unleash attacks
like this personal attacks it's there's
no wonder why he'll leave for a few
months and then try to build up his
confidence and then kind of yeah yeah
really sad but that's why we have to
vote because he gets to vote just like
you and I we've got a great bonus show
for you today I'm out of time to tell
you what's on it but you can get access
as a patron at patreon.com slash david
pakman show or as a member at WWN
pakman.com